we're gonna go through some some sets of
photos about particular project and this
about aspects iconic aspects of San
Francisco anyone who wants to guess what
this first section is what is this is
this is the photographer's friend fog is
so important it's it is our identifying
natural effect but it's very you know it
it covers up works of man that need
covering up and and then there are a few
things that you can actually manipulate
and use for your own usefulness and
unfortunately it's it's not something
actually there somebody now makes a
little a little bug bomb a fog that you
can can use I have the real thing I have
one but I haven't ever used it it
probably doesn't work anymore this is
out not far from where yeah we have a
four point beer on back there that's
looking into the sunset
you think they're in here but there's a
there is a little backstory to this I
was doing it for some magazine a story
on San Francisco and I had had a phone
call that morning from the magazine and
they said Fred we're trying to close
this story but we don't have the fog
picture yet did you promise I said look
you can't cue the fog just when you need
it I'll get it to you soon
I said well if it doesn't get here we'll
have to do the story without it and that
evening my bride and I were invited
upstairs to our landlord was upstairs it
was quite or us a cocktail and when I
was up there he was just about to pour
and I looked out the window and I could
see this string of fog coming and we
lived in Sausalito at the time and I say
oh don't poor ready and I said I promise
you I'll buy you a drink the moment we
finish taking this picture but we have
to go right now
and so we rushed out there that's just
above where Super Bass was and that is
my landlord and my bride and my uncle
Scar and while it looks very romantic if
they're I'm so glad there's no recording
of Fred for Chrysler take the pictures
raising our bums and we're dying
just one more exposure as I had to take
them immediately to the nearest bar very
expensive production nobody made that
you made your deadline made the and
actually we didn't print it again for
another 50 60 years but but now it's in
the book no it's in the book
but we'll get to the book in a minute
okay so so then there's this guy mr.
herb kane so so do you remember when so
so herb kane just to get our our facts
right here i think he started in the 30s
writing for first in sacramento in here
is that sound right he was in sacramento
yeah and he was known as the sacrament a
kid and he appeared here and was an
instant success and herb was unique in
that he really got san francisco and did
a column that was like no other and
nobody has really been a success and
trying to do that again was always
irritated people who said well herb what
are you gonna write something serious
and to me this was a great
accomplishment it I mean there it's it's
hard to explain to someone in a way it's
like you know when there were three
networks and everybody watched Walter
Cronkite and that kind of thing but for
San Francisco there was hurricane I
don't know that most cities ever even
had so much kind of a singular voice
that kind of represented the city in
that way is was is that what you would
say from being have the grant to get I
would say that was true yeah and he
really loved it and and he was so let's
let's just characterize it for folks who
never saw it cuz but first of all for 60
years basically he was writing for The
Chronicle
briefly for the examiner in the midst of
a yeah and that there were times when I
would be going through my cleaning my
desk and I would find it a snap that I
done of him and I would throw it in the
mail to him and once at a party he said
hey Fredo would you do me a great favor
I sure heard what she please don't send
me any more pictures he went through a
period when he had electric hair as it
did everything and then then he went
through a period when he didn't have
enough hair but he was he was out on the
town all the time and when he went when
he went to the examiner
I asked his replacement at the cron how
it was try to write a herbes King
hurricanes column for the crime and he
said it's no hope there are only so many
talking lawyers and talking doctors in
this town and herbs got them all so down
lesser herb wood herb had a a roll of
three by five cards there were a
perforated roll and they were in his his
trusty royal and whenever the phone
would ring he or his assistant would
take whatever came in and if it sounded
like something promising they would type
it on that and it would go into a little
card file and when it came time to put
together a column Europe would go
through that and and rephrase it in
three dot journalism as he'd call and
and and so just and we can't fully
characterize here but but and he started
in the 30s he was writing until the 90s
he was doing six a day six a week rather
six days a week
and then ultimately down to three but
they were these little in a way it's
like a string it's like a Twitter thread
of little little little chunks of things
as you said this sort of index cards
together and it's things that are
happening tips or gossip a little bit
here in there
how would you characterize what well he
was actually writing there were
wonderful little squibs that he had
adjusted to to make them really sing
mm-hmm and you know if you were if you
fed stuff to him regularly every once in
a while he would mention your name and
that was a great thing yeah I found that
my UPS man would always ask me when he
came to the door how's your buddy herb
[Laughter]
everybody does read this
[Music]